good morning believe nation today's
message is enjoy life over to you jamie
dimon go to work a place where you
respect the people you think the company
has the kind of culture you like is it
going to grow is to be ambitious and
your career will take who knows what
path and you know do think I had a
couple of jobs so that you're always
thinking maybe what I might want to do
next and you know one point light you
have to make a vertical switch or some
point life may get fired like some of us
have been you know or and those those
are hard things but they could be very
good thing so some I've also find some
people said that's what they want and
they're looking up those hundred stairs
and always measuring how quickly the
going versus their friend that's it you
know you're not doing the right thing
you're not enjoying your job you're
you're you know it takes a lot of luck
to get to that top rung sometimes and
and if you're really good you probably
get there it may not be at that company
they may be somewhere else so uh I tell
you enjoy your life enjoy every step of
it and don't don't worry too much about
that kind of ambition I remember one of
the first and only jobs that I ever had
was working in a financial institution
and we're working on merging some
documents together and is basically a
bunch of copy and pasting work all day
long day in day out just doing copying
pasting from one thing to the other and
it was super boring work and it's give
him a headache because I had you know
fluorescent lights and as a result I
would bring popcorn into work to kind of
give me some salt and help me get over
the headaches and they told me that I
couldn't have food while I was working
and I used to bring in a headset so I
could listen to music because the work
was pretty boring and they said I
couldn't listen to music and then the
quarterly reports came in and I was on
that team of people maybe six to eight
people and I liked to work like my
default is to work when I'm at home and
you know Nina's not home and Hayden's is
asleep or whatever I'm I'm I work like I
enjoy my work and so I wasn't taking
lunch breaks with my colleagues I was
just working other with who lunch when I
was there from 9:00 to 5:00 where the
hours
I was working and when the quarterly
reports came in I had done more work
than the rest of my team combined that
was six to eight people like one guy was
doing the work of five to seven people
and I was told that I was almost fired
because of my bad habits of wanting to
eat food at my desk and listen to music
but because I was so productive they
kept me on like I should be grateful
that they kept me on and so for the next
couple of weeks
I said bought my popcorn but I like I
hate it in my first drawer the desk and
only opened it can i snack I remember
having to wear a turtleneck to work
every day and I would run a wire I ran
my CD little CD man back in the day I
was on the floor and I ran a wire
through my jeans through my turtleneck
and then just had a little earbud pop up
outside so it could still listen to
music while I worked and it wasn't as
noticeable and I did that for a couple
weeks and then thought this is crazy
like why am I doing this this isn't fun
I'm not enjoying myself here and it was
a typical advice from the people around
me at the time that I need to go get a
job I thought I need to have a job to be
successful it's what my parents did I
said I've been my family did and so this
is one of my first jobs I thought this
was just normal that this was what most
people did and I decided you know what I
can't do this like this sucks I hate
going to work every day I hate just
grinding it out I'm not even allowed to
do the things that make me a little bit
happy and so I left and I think I mean
it's a sad story but had a happy ending
what I think too many people stay in the
sad story I think - and people never
leave to go do something else I think
too many people stick with a life that
they're not happy with that they don't
enjoy that they're just grinding it out
for somebody else helping somebody
else's dream come true instead of
working on their own and what I've tried
to do consistently is if I'm not happy
with something in any area of my life
and it's consistent I make a change and
that might be changing the relationship
it might be changing my schedule they
might be changing a business direction
might be might be a small change some
things are big and some things are a lot
smaller but if I'm unhappy with
something in any area of my life I start
to make a change and I'd encourage you
to do so too like could you
enthusiastically say yes I enjoy my life
and it doesn't mean you enjoy your life
every single day and it's always roses
we're all gonna have our down days but
on the whole do you enjoy your life and
if not what's contributing to you not
enjoying it and then start working on
those changes stop complaining about it
stop just thinking about it stop just
talking about it stop blaming other
people and start actually making changes
to make your life better so that you can
enthusiastically say I enjoy my life
so the question they today is do you
enjoy your life and why or why not leave
in the comments below I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day get you to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event